so you are a professor right and you do
research on your own and all that we've
got your book the consuming instant a
signed copy for you decided already
signed it and if I see it on ebay as a
means for you to try to fund your Malibu
house I'll be upset no no don't worry
about the Malibu house I'm working on it
in other other ways so tell me a little
bit about what what brought you to the
world of academic so I've always known I
mean there were two things that I was
really good at and interested in soccer
and studying books yeah I was certainly
going quite it's my soccer career was
going quite well but then I had some
serious injuries and other circumstances
they don't allow me to pursue that and
so that accelerated my move to academia
and so I always do I mean I didn't take
any breaks between my degrees I just
went through eight strewth of my PhD
it's straight to a professorship well
because I never imagined doing anything
else in terms of the the work that I do
if that's what we talked about so what I
what I do is I basically marry
evolutionary psychology and biology to
the study of consumer behavior so the
idea being that what makes us consume
the way that we are is ultimately rooted
and some evolutionary mechanisms why is
it that men are the ones who are most
likely to succumb to the pornographic
addiction you know what how do women's
hormones throughout their menstrual
cycles affect their behaviors as
consumers and so I look at these
biological underpinnings specifically in
the consumer setting so do you think
that most behaviors most human behaviors
are linked back to genetics more than
anything else I know you've talked about
this yes yes and it's the nature versus
nurture argument and things like that
but would you say that's really where
the stuff were made of I mean certainly
there are two biological imperatives
that are part of our shared you know
human nature but there's always an
interaction between our genes and our
environment and the I always love to use
the cake metaphor so if you take the
ingredients in a cake the the baking
soda the flour the sugar the eggs
they're each separate ingredients then
you put them all together you make a
cake if I were to tell you now point to
the eggs or point to the sugar you
wouldn't be able to it's an
Koval makes and so much of who we are is
an inextricable mix of our nature and
nurture the problem with most social
scientists has been over the past
hundred years is that they have dogged
li refused to accept that biology
matters and so their position has always
been yeah yeah evolutionary theory is
relevant to explain the behavior of the
dog and the mosquito and the zebra but
don't you dare apply it to human
behavior we transcend our biology what
makes us human is that we are cultural
animals and that's silly
well I mean if you were just to look at
people being gay wouldn't that be a
argument against that well right because
wouldn't they by that logic they would
say you could override it or something
like that that's right exactly of course
that's one example but there's a zillion
right I mean I mean it it it behooves
want to understand how serious academics
could genuinely believe that biology
doesn't carry much importance when it
comes to understanding human affairs but
it really originally started from a very
good place a lot of miscreants used
evolutionary theory for nefarious goals
right Hitler misused that you Genesis
misused that social class elitist and
Britain said hey the upper classes are
better than the lower classes who cares
if the lower classes died hey that's
Darwinian of course it had nothing to do
with Darwinian theory but because of all
these you know cretins misuse
evolutionary theory social scientists
said okay well let's create a new
understanding of human nature we're
biology is no longer relevant and
hopefully there won't be these types of
abuses but that's silly I mean you have
to root your science in logic and reason
yeah so my whole direct message at the
top of the show was talking about
academia and sort of the ideas that are
that are working in colleges and mostly
that are not working and the free speech
problems we're having which we're having
hugely here in America but I know it's
happening in Canada too and it's
happening all across Europe right now
and you're you're right in the thick of
that because you are outspoken yeah I
mean that's what why we connected in the
first place I saw this guy on Twitter
and I was like wow this guy gets it and
he's not afraid to say it so what do you
think the general atmosphere or talk
about for your experience what I so you
you might have seen I recently delivered
a lecture on political correctness and
the thought police and I gave many of
these examples which
if they weren't true you would think
it's straight out of the onion I mean
it's really just impossible to imagine
that the fulcrum has has swung so much
towards lunacy mm-hmm I think we have to
fight it I mean the reality is that most
academics I hate to keep repeating this
this point but are afraid of their
shadows their career is to the extent
that the general environment is you have
to coddle the the students you have to
infantilized them don't you dare say
something that might offend them then
they perpetuate the problem but if
enough people stand up courageously and
say look this is not right as my fact
I've had this discussion recently here
with some college students mm-hmm and I
explained to them that it's not to your
benefit to have professors be terrified
to speak to you there's a there's a
great article that I can remember the
name of the professor who wrote it
basically said my students terrify me
that's not a good thing I mean if you're
a student you don't want to hear that
right you want professors will challenge
you who who get you to move from your
positions if we are afraid to utter one
syllable that might somehow necessitate
you going into a safe space it shatters
the possibility for dialogue yeah so
when you say that to students I'm gonna
guess that on an individual level if
you're sitting across from them they
probably do get that they probably
understand it but that when you get them
in a group and the group think stars
right that that's where it becomes
dangerous so um so how do you combat
them patiently by demonstrating through
evidence that this is ultimately
suboptimal and it will only hurt your
growth right
I mean people learn by engaging the
diversity of ideas I mean that's what
learning is about and so and I explained
to them that I'm very open to somebody
coming to see me and saying look I've
experienced this in this trauma and
therefore I need this particular you
know acquiescence and fine I mean I'm a
myth empathetic person I'll take that
into account but to have for example a
trigger warning that is sufficiently
vague that it covers every possible
thing that might trigger somebody that's
not a good idea
right so let's dig into the trigger or
anything a little bit so there are
would be trigger warnings for example if
you were teaching a course and you were
gonna discuss rape they would certain
amount of people that that like these
ideas would want you to issue a trigger
warning so that in case someone that was
in the class had been raped or their
mother had been raped her their sister
had been right for whatever it is they
would it they would receive notice
before discussing it I know that doesn't
sound terrible in and of itself but it's
it's the pervasiveness of it right it's
the way that it then sort of shelters
you from really dealing with at hard
times well and the reality is that it's
not restricted to a few examples such as
rape it becomes everything it's
everything as a matter fact I I I took I
took it upon me to actually generate a
list of topics that have been suggested
as possible topics that would be worthy
of a trigger warning and naxi I covered
that in my in my lecture yeah and
basically those topics that I generated
would pretty much cover anything that
anybody could ever talk about yeah
so how could that be that I mean yeah I
don't know how it could be but yeah yet
here we are where do you think this
started because that's the part that I
find really interesting and I did
discuss it a little bit with Tariq where
did this idea that you have to be
protected come from right and and how
did it proliferate so quickly well I
think it comes from different sources
but political correctness is really the
the impetus of all of these subsequent
movements right yeah the idea that there
are certain things that you should not
say and then we take this idea and then
we say well there are certain things
that you shouldn't say because it makes
people feel uncomfortable or it hurts
them or triggers a past trauma and so it
becomes the way that I've described that
there's and it's a speculative
hypothesis right now but it'd be it's
certainly worth testing there's a
phenomenon known as munchausen syndrome
mmm-hmm which basically says a woman
typically it's a woman who suffers from
this disorder will try to frame an
illness to tend garner sympathy mm-hmm
then there's munchausen syndrome by
proxy where you harm your child or your
pet or your elderly parent to try to
then garner sympathy yeah well I think
this type of crying for safe space is
sort of this grotesque collect
the munchausen syndrome right where
people get attention by constantly
screaming victimhood yeah and so it
becomes a very alluring way to navigate
through the world I always get attention
by saying that I'm offended I'm hurt I'm
right well I escaped execution I could
still watch a military movie right right
I want from now on whenever I walk
around in any city you shut down all
movie theaters you have military because
I was going to be executed Lebanon yeah
do it god I mean it's really nuts when
you when you especially when you lay out
like a great metaphor like that it's
like this is because we could all do
this and that's why every what do they
call it you know it's just like the
afflicted Olympics or the oppression on
the oppression Olympics it's like it it
will never stop yeah and I see this now
as a disease that that's running rampant
and that's why I talk about it so much
yeah I can't imagine that this will
continue
I already see a lot of academics write
to me privately saying to me they don't
yet have the courage to yeah I'm on
board publicly but they say you know
thank you for speaking out thank you for
being a voice of reason this has
empowered me to try to be a bit more
open and I think all it takes is for a
flicker to start and then eventually I
think the tide will shift back yeah well
that's nice to hear that they're
privately doing that but do you get
pushback from professors that think you
know dad's pushing this too much I don't
get it to my face I'm a formidable guy
to go against in other words you better
come with all your guns if you're gonna
do this stuff with me yeah so usually it
doesn't happen directly but I will hear
from some sources that such and such
person is upset that I'm taking these
positions so I know that there are
groups that are upset with me but they
don't necessarily come to my face and
say right so this is a great argument
for tenure right I mean if you you have
tenure eyes oh yeah and since 1999 since
99 so when you got tenure did that
change I'll at that moment did they what
do they do they hand your paper how did
it work they you kneel down and well
it's actually a committee it goes
through several layers and then finally
you receive a letter saying that you've
been granted tenure yeah the process of
applying for it is you basically give
your whole dossier to demonstrate that
your word
of that honor what are the protections
you actually get for tenure I mean they
just can't fire you just like that but
there must be some cause what if they
run out of money if the university
closed is that only if your department
would have to be closed for financial
reasons then that would be ground for
then closing the department the fact
that your tenured wouldn't protect you
right but the purpose of tenure is
really to make sure that let's suppose
I'm doing work on evolutionary
psychology and the Dean is a young earth
creationist who thinks that evolution is
a Zionist hoax all right well he or she
can't come to me and say hey you better
stop this evolution stuff because it
offends me and it makes our university
look bad and I'll fire you right so
tenure is a means by which you ensure
that good ideas are able to be pursued
because oftentimes most of the important
ideas are dangerous ideas they're ideas
that go against the orthodoxy they're
ideas that are considered heretical at
the time right think of Galileo think of
Socrates right and so the the idea
appetising in political discourse
politicians will say oh we've got to get
rid of tenure because all these fad
professors sit around doing nothing yeah
that's that's basically them saying that
they're idiots
because meeting they're not doing their
job right I mean tenure is there to make
sure that you could pursue dangerous
ideas now regarding my specific context
even when I didn't have tenure
I was outspoken maybe not necessarily
about trigger warnings because there
wasn't right but in other words I never
modulated my behavior maybe to a fault
maybe I'm not of enough of a careerist I
just I don't care the the pursuit of
truth for me is greater than any careers
considerations